Vascular separate things here,
one is that I argue in the book that the
ride versus
laughed way of looking at American
politics is very obsolete.
That in fact there are many positions
which used to be called or considered
leftwing,
which impact on us in the center of
American politics and very mainstream
like bring the troops home from Iraq,
a universal healthcare and doing
something about corporate
responsibility,
global warming.
All these issues are now mainstream,
was 60 to 70 percent approval ratings.
So the meeting he had continued to
deposit this false dichotomy of right
versus left on practically every
political issue.
And the other.
The other problem is that when you look
at the facts
and the evidence,
it is not so difficult to realize where
the truth lies.
Then we can have a vigorous discussion
about how to approach the problem or
what to do.
Uh,
but whether I'm there is global warming,
whether evolution is the fact whoever
Iraq is a catastrophe,
it is a pretty clear answers.